Йорг Асмуссен - успішний економіст та фахівець,
проте вільного часу для його маленьких дітям ставало все менше.
Кар'єрне зростання та перехід на роботу
до Європейського Центробанку збіглися з народженням однієї з доньок.
Це вимагало від чоловіка повної віддачі - або сім'ї, або роботі.
Коли постала необхідність переїзду з рідного Берліна до Франкфурта
для роботи в штаб-квартирі Центробанку, Асмуссен звільнився.
У професійних колах це стало сенсацією.
Я був здивований величезному потоку мейлів від колег і знайомих.
Причому, одні називали мене зразком для
наслідування, інші - повним ідіотом.
А цей чоловік погодився на інтерв'ю тільки за умов повної анонімності.
Кілька місяців він "воював" з начальником, щоб отримати право
- бути поруч зі дітьми в перші роки їх життя.
Шеф відхилив моє похання, та ще й познущався:
за дітьми мають стежити жінки, якщо чоловіки починають
цим займатися, то тоді їм варто надіти колготки.
І таке подібне, із зневагою,  - "якщо чоловік
носиться з дитиною, він - ганчірка".
Такі ось допотопні уявлення.
Але нічого не допомогло, відпустку я не отримав.
Чоловік навіть думав про зміну роботи, однак
на цей крок не наважився - занадто великий ризик
на довгий час втратити заробіток.
Йому довелося «проковтнути» не тільки приниження від шефа,
а й змиритися з роллю «тата вихідного дня».
Непросто було і Йоргу Асмуссену. Але зрештою тепер все добре.
Я знайшов хорошу работу с новим роботодавцем.
Він наперед знав, що я дуже серйозно налаштований,
коли кажу - Берлін - це важливо. Через дітей.
І мені відповіли: "Добре, ЦЕ ми вже зрозуміли.
Попри такі випадки, активне батьківство
в Німеччині стає дедалі популярнішим.
За статистикою, відпустку по догляду за кожним
третім народженим малям бере саме чоловік.
Найлегше отримати декрет науковцям, ай-ті фахівцям і лікарям.
У привадному сектрі це також реально,
але якщо піти всупереч волі керівництво, можна забути про підвищення.
Водночас тривалість самої відпустки для чоловіків значно менша:
в середньому три місяці, тоді як жінки перебувають в декреті понад рік.
Держава усіляко заохочує татусів, які беруть
відпустку по догляду за дитиною.
Наприклад, якщо він піде у декрет щонайменше на два місяці,
строк виплат державних грошей на дитину зросте відповідно зросте.